Ja, aber bitte schön.
Ja, okay.
Guten Abend.
Sehr guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Usluogullar.
Ich bin hier, die Habende Ars.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Anamnetsgeschef führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Hauptsache, ich kriege ihn.
Ich möchte das Personal erfangen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Rudolf Pol.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, das ist auch ein bisschen schwierig.
Rudolf schreibt man L, U, D, O, L und dann Ph.
Ja.
Und der vernehmliche Name ist Pol.
Da geht es mit P weiter.
O, H, L.
Pol.
Pol, genau.
Herr Pol, wie alt sind Sie?
Jetzt muss ich gerade rechnen.
Ich bin 1965 geboren.
Wie alt bin ich denn?
Nein, jetzt 2,5 Jahre alt.
2,5 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 16.05.65.
Nein, ich bin 1965.
Okay.
Hier.
Stimmt das überhaupt?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe falsch gerechnet.
70.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Sag mal, bin ich denn der nicht?
35?
57 bin ich.
Ich rechnen das sonst immer vorher aus.
Hier steht es ja, auf 56 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,82 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
89 kg.
Okay, gut.
Ja, Herr Pol, was führt Sie zu uns?
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe seit einigen Tagen so ein ganz hässlichen Husten.
Da kommt auch so grünes Zeug raus.
Und jetzt habe ich wirklich hohes Fieber.
Nachtschwitzig wie verrückt.
Ich kriege jetzt auch nicht so gut Luft.
Mir tut der ganze Brustkopf weh.
Ich habe auch Kopfschmerzen.
Ich fühle mich also total krank.
Herr Pol, seit einigen Tagen Husten Sie haben gesagt.
Haben Sie Ihre Fieber gemessen?
Ja, das war über 39.
Können Sie beschreiben, wie es Ihre Husten gibt?
Es gibt auch Wurzschöpf, Sputum oder?
Ja, da kommt auch nicht etwas raus.
Wie ist die Farbe der Sputum?
Das sieht so gelbgrünlich aus, ganz rücklich.
Können Sie Brut in der Sputum bemerken?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nein, das ist nicht aufgefallen.
Sie haben Atemnot?
Sie haben Sie immer Atemnot?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich nicht genug Luft kriege.
Im Ruch auch Belastung?
Nein, ich kann mich gar nicht belasten im Augenblick.
Da ist ja schon ein bisschen zu viel Luft.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich nicht genug Luft kriege.
Da ist ja schon der Weg von 5 Metern im Haus.
Im Haus ist er schon zu weit.
Ich komme ja kaum vorwärts.
Okay, ja, verstanden.
Ich habe das auch berutschen lassen.
Ich habe es auch erwähnt.
Ich habe es auch über Übelkeit erbrechen.
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Das ist nicht so.
Nein, das ist nicht das Problem.
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine oder haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein, das ist nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie auch Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, ich habe immer mal ein bisschen Blähung.
Nein, das ist nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe immer mal ein bisschen Blähung.
Aber dass ich jetzt in diesem Zusammenhang Bauchschmerzen habe,
das ist mehr so hier oben in dem Pustbereich.
Haben Sie viele ähnliche Symptomen gehabt?
Nein, ich kenne das gar nicht.
Klar hat man mal Husten, aber ich habe so einen Husten noch nie gesagt.
Ja, mit Auswurf.
Und Fieber, seit einigen Tagen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Zugang?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Und Sie haben erwähnt, ich habe verstanden.
Ja, in der Nacht schwitze ich so.
Da wache ich auf und bin klatschnastgeschwitzt.
Ja, haben Sie Nachschweiß dann?
Ja, ja, ja.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Im Augenblick habe ich natürlich überhaupt keinen Appetit.
Normalerweise ist das nicht mein Problem.
Seit einigen Tagen.
Ja, seit es mir so schlecht geht, habe ich natürlich auch keinen Hunger.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie vor der Beschwerden
ungewöhnliche Situation erlebt haben?
Das ist mir, also ich bin nicht irgendwie verreist.
Oder habe ich nicht mehr mitgekommen?
Nein, ich habe nicht mehr mitgekommen.
Ich habe nicht mehr mitgekommen.
Ich habe nicht verreist.
Nein, nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ganz normal meine Arbeit gemacht.
Und gibt es
oder, ja, gibt es
ähnliche Symptome,
Personen zuhause, zum Beispiel?
Nein, da wusstest du es im Augenblick.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Corona Personen Kontakt gemacht?
Nein, nein, nein. Ich bin ganz vorsichtig und ich bin auch geimpft.
Ich meine meine Kinder, ich habe ja große Kinder.
Und die leben noch in der Familie zum Teil.
Aber eigentlich sind wir alle sehr vorsichtig und besitzt.
Ich habe schon einige Sachen.
Also einmal habe ich chronische Rückenschmerzen.
Dann habe ich auch mal ein Bruthochdruck.
Was ich habe, ist tatsächlich, ich habe eine Bruthochdruck.
Ich habe eine Bruthochdruck.
Was ich habe, ist tatsächlich ein Gicht.
Das habe ich seit fünf Jahren.
Da hatte ich jetzt vor fünf Wochen einmal sehr heftige Geschwerden
mit so einem richtigen Gichtanfall in einer großen See.
Das sind ja wirklich starke Schmerzen.
Das war sehr unangenehm.
Deswegen weiß ich das noch.
Aber sonst, ja, was ich, wo ich noch aufpassen muss,
bei Sonnenbestrahlung.
Ich habe in den Schlefenbereich so eine Stelle,
die sich verändert bei Sonne.
Und da muss ich immer noch...
Zinsi Besa gewordun,
Gekin Gischanfay.
Ja, natürlich.
Als der Anfang vorbei war, war es ja wieder gut.
Ja, und habe Sie noch an der chronischen Krankheit?
Nein, wie gesagt, die Rücken spazt
und dann eben diese Sonnenempfindlichkeit der Haut an der Schwebe.
Und da, das waren eigentlich so die Sachen.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder geregelt nicht Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme Zylurik 300.
Wie bitte?
Zylurik 300.
Zylurik...
Wofia nehmen Sie zylurik?
Oh, wofür nehme ich Zylurik?
Keine Ahnung, wofür das gut ist.
Hab mir der Arzt verschrieben.
Und dann habe ich noch so Gehe,
was ich im Sommer auf die Haut austrage.
Hm, normal.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein?
Ne, sonst nehmen wir nichts ein.
Medikamente gegen Gist.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das ist normalerweise nicht so schlimm.
Aber jetzt hatte ich halt einmal Probleme.
Und jegen Sie bei Bedarf Medikamente
gegen chronische Rückenschmerzen,
Igbo-Burufen oder?
Ja, gut, dass Rückenschmerzen,
da nehme ich schon mal Igbo-Jahr doch, das schon.
Ja, ich möchte ein Gefräge.
Sie haben erwähnt, Sie haben Brustschmerzen.
Ja.
Sind die Schmerzen andere Körperteile auswahlen?
Austrailen.
Nicht strailen, nicht auch.
Nicht strailen.
Und sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen und wieder weg?
Ja, also insbesondere beim Brusten
tut das natürlich strecklich wie, ja?
Wenn man sich so anstrengt.
Aber es ist eigentlich auch seit Tagen,
dass ich so beim Atmen schon das Gefühl habe,
das mit dem Video, das macht man ja die ganze Zeit.
Ne?
Nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente ein?
Ja, bisher habe ich jetzt noch nichts genommen,
weil ich gehofft habe, der Rücken geht wieder weg.
Ich habe dann mal viel Tee getrunken und so, aber...
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich...
Ja, Sie haben erwähnt, so eine Allergie.
Genau, genau.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Allergie auf Amoxicillin.
Amoxicillin.
Wie äußert die Allergie sich?
Da kriege ich so einen Hautausschlag,
so roter Pickelchen.
Und haben Sie noch andere Allergie?
Nein.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag.
Wie lange gehen Sie?
Ja, seit ich 20 bin, rauche ich das schon, ja.
23 Jahre.
Wie seit ich 20 bin?
Ja, ich weiß ich bin, okay.
Also 37 Jahre.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so ein Bier mal am Abend oder mein Glas Wein im Gesellschaft,
aber nicht viel.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie schon Drogen probiert?
Nein, leider habe ich noch nicht probiert.
Gut.
Und sind Ihre Eltern gesilnt
oder haben Sie chronische Krankheiten, wie ich wissen sollte?
Ja, also chronische Krankheiten, mein Vater hatte halt eine Staublunge,
weil er in Bergbau gearbeitet hat.
Aber das ist ja keine chronische Erkrankung.
Wie bitte, wo arbeitet er?
Er hat in Bergbau gearbeitet.
Bergbau gearbeitet.
Ja.
Da hat eine Staublunge, ja.
Und wie ist Ihre Mutter?
Weil meine Mutter, die ist eigentlich okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, das eine Kind hat ein Down syndrome.
Das ist schwierig zu erzielen.
Und was ist Ihr Beruf?
Ich bin Florist.
Wie bitte, nochmal?
Ja, Florist.
Ich arbeite also in einem großen Blumengeschäft
und berate da die Kunden
und mache der Arrangements und so etwas.
Ja, Herr Schult.
Ich hatte noch letzte Frage.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit auch das Genom?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, ich glaube.
Ich fühle mich immer noch das gleiche, ja.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Waren Sie schon im Ausland?
Sie haben nicht gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, ich war nicht im Ausland.
Sie haben mich nur gefragt, ob ich etwas Besonderes gemacht habe.
Da habe ich gesagt, ich bin nicht verreist.
Also ich war nirgendwo an einem gefährlichen Ort.
Sie haben erwähnt, Sie wurden gegen Corona vollständig geimpft.
Genau, die ganze Familie.
Ja, Herr Paul.
Ich habe für mich alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich glaube, ich habe Ihnen alles beschrieben,
was mich jetzt quält im Augenblick.
Ich bin nur so erschöpft, dass ich wirklich froh wäre,
wenn ich mich irgendwo hinlegen könnte.
Ja, ich kann, ja jetzt kann ich nicht bestimmte Diagnose sagen.
Ich muss so erst einige diagnostische Massnahme durchführen.
Aber wahrscheinlich haben Sie eine Lungenessendung.
Aber natürlich muss ich sie körperlich untersuchen.
Und eine Bruströntgen durchführen.
Und natürlich, ich werde die Stoffsetung 20-30 Meter kontrollieren.
Und die Laborabnahme durchführen.
Dann ist das nicht mehr so.
Ja.
Aber natürlich, ich würde gerne einen Piba Senken Tabete geben.
Aber du heißt, ich muss Ihre Fieber messen.
Danach kann ich Ihnen Fieber Senken Tabete geben.
Ah ja, das ist gut.
Haben Sie Fragen?
Gibt Fragen aus dem Plenum?
Vielleicht eine Hinweise.
Wenn Sie so viel Rüsten haben oder Atemnot haben,
vielleicht könnten wir etwas Sauerstoff geben, gleichzeitig.
Wer wäre für mich nett gewesen, ja.
Ja, so erst muss ich Sauerstoffsetung prüfen.
Wenn es niedrig ist, soll ich BGA Brutgasanalyse durchführen.
Danach würde ich Sauerstoff mit Nasenshonda geben.
Gibt es sonst noch Fragen?
Offensichtlich nicht.
Dann können wir jetzt gucken.
Sind Sie schon so weit?
Ja, ja.
Ja, gut.
Ja, Frau Oberarsten, haben Sie seit ich möchte Ihnen einen Patient vorstellen.
Ja, alles klar.
Herr Rudolf Pol, Herr Pol ist seit dem Jahr 1937.
Er ist 1,82 m groß und 89 kg schwer.
Der Patient kam heute seit einigen Tagen aufgetretenen Beständerung.
Er hat die Brust mit Schiputung gemäß.
Der Patient berichtete, dass er das Knöpfe und Fieber haben.
Er hat sein Fieber gemäß.
Der Patient hat keine Medikamente dagegen eingenommen.
Er hat nur die Erhabe getrunken.
Er hat eine Erhabe mit einem Husten-Attack.
Er hat eine andere Erhabe.
Der Patient klagte über Nachschweiß und in Appätenz wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Kommt Sie vorstellen.
Der Patient hatte keine Beschwerden.
Er wurde gegen Corona vorstandengereift.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Er hatte keine Kontakt mit Corona-Impfung.
Er hat eine Frage nach anderen Sämtungen.
Der Patient hatte Corona-Lombargie.
Er hatte einen Schiff von 4 Wochen.
Er hat gut behandelt.
Er hat eine Regelmedikamente mit 300 mg.
Er hat eine andere Erhabe.
Der Patient hatte eine Zonalergie.
Er hat eine andere Erhabe mit einem Husten-Attack.
Er hat eine halbe Packung Zigaretten.
Er hat seit 37 Jahren Ertrinken gelegen.
Er hat ein Alkohol.
Er hat eine andere Erhabe.
Aufgrund der anamnächtigen Angaben gehe ich von Verdacht auf COPD-Exhalvation.
Ich musste die Pynomonie auszuschließen.
Ich werde die Anamnächtigen körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde die Anamnächtigen körperlich unterschließen.
Er hat eine andere Erhabe mit einem Husten-Attack.
Ich werde die Torachsrundung im Zwei-Ebenen und im Lateral durchführen.
Dort kann ich die Infiltration feststellen.
Was machen Sie denn Laborteil nicht?
Was lassen Sie im Labor noch untersuchen?
Ich muss natürlich die Kulturen durchführen.
Ich werde die Thomas-Computer-Thomografie durchführen.
Ich habe dafür an COPD-Exzertivation gedacht, dass die Patientin sehr lange rauchig ist.
Aber das ist eine Verdachtdiagnose.
bestätigen würde, dass der Patient eine Pneumonie hat. Was machen sie dann mit ihm?
Ja, ich habe Schubutum Kultur gemacht oder durchgeführt. Ich muss Antibiotische Therapie
umstellen. Ja, worauf müssen Sie noch achten bei der Antibiotische?
Die Patienten haben alle die Eben am Oxysilin. Ich habe die Eben aufgestellt, dass ich eine Leberflugstasin oder eine Siproflugstasin oder Sektreaktion habe.
Je nachdem, was für ein Keim wird. Ja, was geben Sie ihm denn noch an Medikamenten?
Ja, natürlich werde ich eine Siproflugstasin oder Siproflugstasin.
Was bringt der Patient?
Er hat eine Siproflugstasin oder Siproflugstasin.
Ich muss zuerst Zugang legen.
Dann bekommt er seine Medikamente und überprüft die Sauerstoffsättigung.
Dann sind wir eigentlich soweit fertig. Hier ist noch gefragt worden, welche Apparativen untersucht man macht.
Da haben Sie ja schon gesagt.
Dann haben Sie noch nachgefragt, welche Apparativen untersucht man macht.
Was ist Prodagra?
Prodagra ist die Geistanfalle.
Das haben die Prüfer hier noch nachgefragt.
Ist doch super gelaufen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich noch jemanden von Ihnen ergänzt habe.
Dr. Gündlüs.
Vielen Dank.
Alper ist sehr gut.
Ich denke, für morgen muss er sich keinen Kopf machen.
Wir halten trotzdem einen Daumen.